welcome to this video playing Johannes
Johannes h Johannes harm journey and in
German pronunciation let's see Kings
Indian modern c5 all kinds of stuff even
a groom fraud as possible yeah it is a
groom shot slightly weird move order for
that but sometimes they play it like
that even okay maybe it's not the total
eggs but then I played with h4 hoping
for a weird and complicated game okay
the castles I think no age five is
really interesting hmm okay huh so how
do we play this now take on g6 or age 6
mm how to tell let's take so we get the
H file open hmm what I really want is
the Queen to h4 quickly is there a way
to do it I wonder maybe if I take here
okay i were to readd opening but ok that
leads to leads to fun games yeah I
thought about that but I was thinking
that the open age file is really
changing things a little bit him if I go
Boop d2 for example yes this night this
night if formal but even Bishop h6 is a
mafia takes rook takes night before this
Queen deform let's do this come on it is
really am really crazy all of that but
at least it's early it's some early
early conflict yeah I think it looks
good for white isn't it i mean this this
seems to be tricky for for black
something like 94 Bishop g7 King g7
Queen default check it's definitely good
for wine I mean really good for white if
he takes rook takes 9424 yeah this is of
course possible and I'm thinking that if
I just go queen d 4 h 4 isn't this may
be good shouldn't take take so long
Queen d2 was also interesting but then
maybe rope the aid this even even more
of a problem that looks wrong to me
really for some reason it looks wrong to
me 95 maybe and night see for you start
with that dorm
take you maybe I'm taking first not sure
about it 95 yes this should be good then
this is hanging on g4 that's night c4
and also Queen f4 possibly okay 96
it's not that convincing actually how do
we add them and yeah I guess I'll take
it we should be six I have Queen f4 with
the tempo
jump b2 is hanging and I don't see what
to do here it's also c5 hey if I can so
long there is this really route before
yeah I don't know i probably have to
take this this move with a tempo then
maybe Cass along and yeah this looked
totally wrong everything for black but I
didn't refute it really didn't
now maybe Bishop h5 it's not such a bad
idea yeah can it be to a singing and it
is also c5 vain and also look Brooke
before so as a problem a very very
strange stuff i have f 3g for that's the
only thing that really might help me but
look before I mean April deform maybe
look T for saving me I don't have to
move the Queen maybe Ruby 44 there's
also stuff like a 5 which looks kind of
dangerous Wow okay
that I totally don't understand rook be
aight i can take at the time when shall
also take that is a total meltdown you
probably really thought root be a
disposal black resigns well from a
really critical position to win quickly
yeah he can I don't know here's how the
rook t4 is still ok maybe it's true and
he can just take him yeah my king is not
snot safe I don't know maybe the same
and then try to try to do this but it's
it's it's tough rookie eight maybe
totally unclear I would like to see how
I could have refuted this opening which
i'm pretty sure as possible this is does
not look right really really not see
takes 25 it seems is just winning ok ok
now I'm not winning really not winning
compass going down with this evaluation
check check this looks very very
dangerous for black compass giving wider
pretty substantial advantage interesting
ok but I went with this and now Quincy
one is winning ok it's not difficult why
don't I play this mmm
it's really easy right you can do that
but I just have to have this funny idea
check and I'm totally winning out there
was it was wrong what he did but I
couldn't end early viewed it yeah the
main point was all the main problem was
that I didn't really see knight c6
correctly if I go Queen fim still much
better it is a problematic position
frame but now he really got to got his
development going queena for was
probably better yeah this was the
relatively best move this is well yeah
so at least I defended this correct
Liberty just when did to hoops just went
into total meltdown this is just not
working maybe he was thinking rook v8
but I mean I tour I really don't
understand that even let's say I mean I
can't take it and I will take it but
even if I just move here i'm winning
really a very mysterious so he must have
seen something totally am hallucinating
I know yeah I should have really won
this out of the opening okay thanks for
watching